foreign
[Music]
my virtual audience uh welcome to my
session today I'm going to talk about a
topic on the addressing temporal Trends
in real world evidence of treatment
effects
um uh this is a a project I did during
my postdoc at Harvard so my most of my
collaborators here they are from Harvard
Medical School and School of Public
Health
so first of all as required by the data
provider we have a we have to make this
disclosure that uh
um the study is sponsored by American
and the data for the project is provided
by the project data Sofia the website
but they um are not responsible for
um our like conclusions and there's no
additional conflict interest to announce
so here is an overview of the talk today
first I will briefly introduce the
background like you know why EHR is
useful for advancing Cancer Care uh so
we start with a winning strategy of its
benefit and then point out two key
challenges that we are about to resolve
in the study that one is the curation of
an analysis data from Eritrea the other
is to a correcting for the confounding
which I would Define if you haven't
heard of it uh especially with this uh
temporal Trends over time and to
Showcase uh the you know the the the
challenges and also our solution we
focus on a study of emulation of the a a
randomized thing called trial uh which
is a paper published this year
um we talk about uh three aspects one is
the data curation that we uh talk about
the variable grouping and the
phenotyping and the natural language
processing technique that prepare the
data and uh we then we talk about how
can we use causal inference tools to
model the data that we use the W robust
estimation with code train temporal
period stratified models and in the end
we will show the analysis results from
the real of the evidence that we
successfully emulate the venmass
clinical trial and we will list the
temporal trends that detected in the
process
uh to start with uh let me show you this
you know a diagram uh showing like a why
HR is so great so basically in a
traditional study
um we have to take a lot of like a long
time uh for study from the recruitment
uh through the initiation and end of
follow-up and analyzing reporting right
so most of the time it lacks uh doing
this follow-up we have to wait until
those outcome of interesting happen
right however in your trust that study
the data has been routinely collected
collected by the providers right so then
when we Access Data those hard work had
been done by them
we immediately have all this history of
treatment initiation and the future
outcome after the you know the treatment
and all we have to do is uh you know do
the analysis and Reporting so the study
cycle are much shorter and and this
mimics the winning strategy of some you
know uh deep learning math like a first
generation of alpha gold like we learned
from the past games right so this is
like a year chart is this past game of
healthcare and um
once we have this fossil turnover the
other benefit is like we don't have uh
to you know recruit additional labor to
conduct the study because you know all
these uh providers have already prepared
the data for us and so that we can use
EHR study to supplement traditional
study in many ways for example we can do
pyramid screening for uh resource
allocation and in case of uh like uh
like a pandemic we can also use EHR as
the first response to the crisis before
any traditional study can kick-start
right so and also we might use
alternatively the tool to assist
Recruitment and the follow-up like to uh
run like programmatic trial for example
with year trial assistance
so
um first first of all like we we want to
uh describe like what is this uh you
know this uh the word in the title real
word of evidence like how it's different
from uh the random clinical trials so
this is relevance clinical trials are
still considered a gold standard uh in
defining the treatment guidelines but uh
we have to acknowledge they're good but
they have certain limitation the first
of all like they have uh um lack of
generality right so the real world
patient population uh they're usually
different from the eligible patients in
the trials uh we kind of usually we see
like child cohort they are healthier in
general
um and um and uh also for the um um
random rescue trial they have a focus on
studying the efficacy on the uh
treatment treatment or the intervention
and uh somehow the effectiveness that's
you know the treatment assignment in a
real world setting usually they are they
are accompanied by many other uh like
components right so they go in a dynamic
way so uh for that reason like you know
if you we only focus on the drug or the
intervention uh effect that's the
efficacy we cannot describe fully the
you know the whole set of the uh
treatment
um kind of package right so in the real
world setting the effectiveness and also
of course we have mentioned that this is
cost a lot of money so if the study do
not have a financial incentive then we
might have us not have a sponsor for
that and also we might have uh um like a
difficulty recruiting enough
patient fund a single site right to for
like rare uh outcome or like rare
diseases but for EHR we can you know
um combine different size easily because
just the data moving not people moving
uh together right
so and uh uh thanks to the up coders
like a adoption of EHR in the United
States we have almost like a 96 of the
hospital system have uh EHR ready I
think this number probably is growing
already uh from Once I collected and in
the EHR we have a comprehensive
information about the history of patient
Health from those structured uh data
that collected through the uh the
interactive tables and also we have the
medical notes that in the narrative uh
format and also all kinds of lab values
and
uh biomarkers now these are more popular
we also have images from uh different uh
you know diagnosis tools
um so we have like a real really a
promising uh Prospect like using ears
for all kinds of study including cancer
however but from some Insider in
Industry it seems like there's limited
profit from you know for example big
company like Google the reason is
um the EHR data had like a healthcare
data are much more complicated than
games like chess or go right so we have
intrinsic noise in medical outcomes you
don't really know win or loss instantly
right and also EHR data itself uh it is
not far it is far from ready to go and
I'm going to explain a little bit more
so the first challenge I'm gonna race is
like for using EHR for medical research
like uh there is usually no precise
variable extraction available uh the
information about uh the uh clinical
variable that they're useful for the
study are usually scattered uh Acro
around like the vast years data set we
have like a millions of variables uh in
total
um for each patient however like to find
the one that's relevant for for example
a disease diagnosis or certain
progression of the disease is very hard
right one thing is like there is arrows
for those calls you can think of easily
you know they have the same name the
other things for certain
um variables like a disease progression
we don't really have one to one precise
indicator in the data set there's no
code called cancer progression in the
year trans system so it traces a
challenge for us to do cancer research
so traditionally we have relied on
effort review so basically like you know
the the we would have some disease like
a domain expert they are trained
Physicians for the disease they will
read through the
medical notes and then uh they will
annotate manually uh the the variables
we need and as if they are filling this
uh uh study reporting form right so in
the traditional way however this is very
slow and costly so in this project I'm
going to introduce like a a recent
development that we have more scalable
automated extraction tools one is
phenotapping that we can learn diseases
and symptoms and second is natural
electric processing that we are able to
extract a documentation directly from
the narrative notes and we can combine
these tools with you know fewer much
fewer number of expert review for
validation and the tuning of these
methods
so here is basically a um a integrated
data curation pipeline for preparation
of uh real world elements and Analysis
data from uh EHR data so this is another
ongoing project today we won't focus on
the details that pipeline but just give
you a brief overview that we start with
the variable matching of the uh the key
we identify the key uh clinical
variables in the RCT design and then map
to the list of ear track features and in
the second step we will extract uh the
cohort that's relevant to the study like
either with the disease or they have
underwent a certain treatment and third
we extracted the the needed clinical
variable using the tools I have
mentioned and in the end we prepare the
some like expert reviewed annotations
for the tuning of this method and the
validation and of course for some robust
subsequent analysis
so another issue with uh using EHR for
treatment Effectiveness comparison is
like we are dealing with observation of
that right so data is not is given so
the treatment assignment is not
randomized so it's really uh what is you
know decided by The Physician according
to their knowledge of the patient's uh
status so we have to account for
compounding so to give you an idea uh
what is confounding uh here is an
example of from that our study a case
study so if we want to study the
patients with early stage colon cancer
and the type of their collectomy so
basically they are treated with a
collectomy one is the traditional one
that's called open collectomy and it's
uh we you know we have a better view of
an app to me so assume presumably this
more operating space but then is a newer
uh a trend trend is called the
laparoscopy assist uh collectomy is less
invasive so you know probably will have
a better recovery rather after the
procedure and uh here to give you an
example what is confounding like a stage
cancer stage is a confounder because it
has first
um due to you know we observe from the
data due to the cautiousness initially
uh the newer procedure was more often
given to healthier like patients with
lower stage right so it also she was a
treatment decision the second is like a
the lower stage is also associated with
better cancer survival which people you
know all know so Associates the outcome
so one whenever a variable like
associated with uh treatment and the
outcome at the same time we call it
confounder in a culture inference
so if we ignore this confounding effect
just contrast marginal mortality of this
OC group versus Lac group it does not
fairly reflect a difference right
because you know
Lac might seems better simply because
they have more patients with lower stage
right so it doesn't really tell like
this procedure is more uh it's better
so um uh another element uh which is a
new that uh you know kind of in the uh
ehl studies like we usually have a long
time span of collecting data so we for
example for this study we collect data
starting from 276 to 2019 so many things
have changed like you know Target a lot
of Target therapies are like uh
underwent a clinical trial and then they
approved and they're put into use
gradually and become more popular and
moving up their lives you know from the
second to first right so a lot of things
have changed so
um and we also see related to the uh the
surgery like the Lac has been
increasingly given to even stage three
patients over time and also like I
mentioned like the the better management
of late stage patient like a adjuven um
human therapy and you know better Target
therapy and immunotherapy might narrow
like a shorten the Gap in survival
across different stages right so we also
have a change of outcome associated with
over time right so then this uh
Distortion of treatment fat you know
confounding is the the strength of
confidence is different right maybe it's
stronger in the beginning and I think
it's getting weaker and weaker over the
time so it's like this time trend is
also a thing we need to take into
consideration
so the way we solve this problem through
uh statistical modeling is basically two
folds versus targeting the confounding
itself we have to start with a broad
list of Compounders like stage uh I'm
gonna you know give example like how
broad this can be and second we're gonna
learn things you know the defining uh
characters like it must associate with
those treatment mechanism and outcome so
we have to learn the effect on treatment
decision
um and to adjust the the arms
accordingly so that we can correct for
you know those discrepancy of
features imbalance of these features in
different arms and second we have to
adjust for their contribution in the
outcome right so uh uh in another model
and uh since these are two models then
uh in order to combine this model and
provide a better more powerful
estimation we would use the doubly
robust estimation in the end and to
address this temporal trans income
founding uh we include a calendar
time as the covariate and uh we would
describe the temporal Trends by the
interaction uh including the uh as
additional coveted interaction between
all the existing variables the broad
list of Compounders with the kind of the
time
of course we can do better like using
other more advanced tools but for this
study we're just making more transparent
so we use a kind of time as a
stratification and since we would create
additional a lot of you know additional
feed variables covest here with the
interaction so we need to do a
selections variable and also an
interaction to control the variance
right
so here is the uh the uh the study
design of our case study of the
emulation of the cost group trial this
trial was reported um a new Ninja of
medicine in 2004 and we are trying to
use the uh the data at the Mass General
breakam EHR to emulate the trial yeah
and
the RCT has a recruits the patient with
stage one to three column cancer and the
two arms they are uh Lac versus OC and
outcome of interest is overall style or
Os and the service were done um in uh
between 2006 uh like 1996 to 2001 and
they are followed up for you know uh up
additional three years so the result was
reported in 2004 and the data is
published on a project data so few so
that's the you know main reason why we
picked this one as the uh the one that
to be emulated because we have
individual level data available and we
stratify our eotra collectomy
um spending from 2006 and 2000 uh um 17
into three temporal Trends so they're
divided from like you know 2006 to 2009
and 2010 to 2013 and 2014 2017.
uh and here is the the study design uh
flow chart so uh we have basically two
blocks uh first is the data curation and
we start with the construction of a
colon cancer cohort and we go into
finding the patient with the appropriate
indication and basically treat it by
collecting at the right timing and then
we go through a list of Eligibility
about their cancer and tumor
characteristics and then we extract
additional features therefore uh um like
a compounding adjustment and in a data
analysis part that we uh develop uh the
the time we we construct a Time depend
model so account for the confounding
especially with this temporal Trend and
we to uh minimize uh the the the
variance right to have a better accuracy
we co-train the model from different um
uh uh the time temporal periods with
some data model selection tools to you
know making them close together no data
evidence uh suggesting otherwise and
then we will be able to produce a
comparison between Lac versus OC in
overall survival for all years and
stratified for each uh like a temporal
period and to evaluate the the
uncertainty we use a numpy Metro
bootstrap
um so uh for the construction for uh
first we talk about the data creation uh
it was in detail so we start with the
broad scanning of uh uh more than um uh
65 or almost 66 000 patients ever with a
colon cancer code that we we obtained
from the POS catalog uh mapping
um and and then we used a unsupervised
phenotyping method which called the map
score to uh narrow down uh the the the
the you know the number the the the the
colon cancer patients uh this tool uses
the diagnosis code and mentioned of uh
um column cancer in medical nodes and we
would uh expect a patient with colon
cancer they have a routine EHR reference
of the cancer and then for other
patients you know they might have
occasional reference but it wouldn't be
regular right so if positive and notice
and we the method use a mixture a
personal model uh to distinguish from
the patient with colon cancer versus
other patients
and then we ask experts review 100
patients randomly sample from the data
uh for their true colon cancer disease
status as a gold standard labels and we
will choose uh a cut off using a map
with uh 95 specificity
and then in the data indications part we
first bring down the type of colectomy
that the patient Atlanta went uh we uh
have we based on the uh description of
the CPT code the procedure code we focus
on those with a partial collab colectomy
on the single column segment so
basically it has to be a partial collect
me code and the patient cannot have
multiple locations right
appearing on the same day for the for
the surgery
and also we would uh
um exclude uh you know uh if multiple
colectomy codes uh uh uh uh are recorded
in the same weekend that means the
procedure might be more complicated
there's multiple surgeries
and the timing of the colostomy in the
EHR design is not specified but
everybody uh enrolled they are
um they receive their you know
um collect me within 40 days uh after
their uh diagnosis and so we also have
this 90 days window to uh require you
know if the question must be done right
away to match as close as possible uh
the the Redman's clinical trial
and then uh we extract the the clinical
conditions
um uh from the EHR as a uh to match the
eligibility criterious uh there are like
a prior or concurrent cancer Crohn's
disease are acutely abstract column we
use the fee code that is tied to this
disease and symptoms and use as an
indicator if the patient haven't seen
that we will exclude them if they have
that in a five-year or one year or three
year window depending on the nature of
the disease and we also use a natural
lecture in processing tools that that
extract the numerical numbers from the
natural nodes uh to uh to learn that
stage for example if the menstrual for
metastasis or the stage flowing with any
um a numerical number and also uh to uh
be more specific to colon cancer because
you know the patient might have other
diseases also have a stage so we would
use the relevance measure to see how
close a colon cancer is mentioned in the
vicinity of those stage and the
numerical number extraction
the tour is called the knife
and here is the uh uh the the data uh
creation uh curation flowchart uh so
starting with uh you know like I said
the 66 000 patient we go go down layer
by layer so we end up with a uh you know
uh what 1000 around 1000 patients that's
uh eligible for the study so it means
like you know uh the uh it shows another
evidence that the randomized clinical
trial they are really not generalizable
in a way that it's a in the broad
population is only a few a very small
fraction of the patient will qualify for
a trial
so then we move on to the statistical
analysis part so we talk about that we
need to in order to capture as much
company as possible we'll have to start
uh compile broad list of the potential
confounders so here is a candidate list
that uh for a future reference we first
include all these you know variables
considered uh in our city also you know
available in that data uh open source
data so that's the gender cancer stage
tumor location and if there's a coded
notation or not and we also include
other demographic features even if it's
not important in the for the
um trial data so including race gender
uh so race and age and colectomy and we
are including additional clinical
features uh that's potentially relevant
uh to the study for example obesity is
reported uh you know associated with uh
lacroscopia sister
um uh procedure because I think it might
raise some technical issue in the
beginning so people are a bit hesitant
but then we we have a later study
showing that you know it's okay so then
we have a growing number of disease so
that's potentially a confounding and
then uh we also have uh some alternative
whole lacking procedural code for right
and significant column cancer that
indicating there might be a different
procedure being done here and we also
have a construct a uh Healthcare
utilization that's basically the volume
of the total number of healthcare
encounters showing how healthy the
patient is in general we also have uh uh
the prior diagnosis of each thing
individual diseases
um a group up to the freeos catalog for
the overall history and the within one
year prior to the collect committee and
we like as we said we stratify the
patient into three uh temporal periodic
groups
and we have three models to describe uh
first the uh the patient the
characteristic distribution difference
between the uh EHR population with uh
the uh RCT population use the density
exponential tilt density ratio model
then we use a logistic regression model
to describe the treatment assignment
candle or the propensity score then we
use a Cox model for the outcome
regression or describing the overall
survival right for each arm and Analysis
methods like we first marginal screen to
find you know variables uh strongly
associated with uh either the treatment
assignment of Lac or the outcome of the
the outcome of Interest overall survival
and then with uh uh within the uh the
screen positive variables we will run a
model selection method called adapter
lasso to find the the signals that's you
know really strong predictors support
treatment assignment and overall
survival and then we would regulate the
temporal interactions that we allow some
flexibility of they are different over
time we want to push them close together
if there's no strong evidence right to
minimize some of the reduce of the
estimation certainty we use group lasso
for that and in the end after we train
this model we put that into a formula
that's uh Guided by the W robust
estimation method all these formulas are
available in the appendix of the paper
so here is the analysis result that we
got from our emulation so we have four
uh plus here uh first one is about all
year comparison we pull all the patients
together and the the the the from the
second and to the to the fourth they are
stratified analysis into each temporal
period and uh the red curve uh is the um
the Lac group and the green uh or the um
turquoise curve is the
um
uh the OC group and the the band around
this uh Point wise now 95 kind of dense
interval from a non-priment
bootstrapping you can see using our like
a temporal Trend uh like adjusted
analysis we are able to uh uh have a
very uh similar uh like a result like
the target RCT if you look at the all
year analysis that uh we have a very
closely knit together and uh lines for
the two arms and they're comfortable
overlap right so it's similar for the
solid solids is our animation the dash
ones is pulled from the RCT so very
close and also across a different year
group uh we see that the survival is
generally improving it's going up right
but still we are able to uh show that
they are um not much significantly
different from each other between our AC
and OC
and here is a uh you know a chart that
we're trying to compress all the
temporal Trend information into one
breath so uh uh you know you can pause
and read later but here the color is the
model coefficient for our propensity
score model and Cox model and the box
size give us the to basically the change
of distribution of the future over time
right and the if we have a side by side
box for the Cox model it means like uh
the the uh coefficient is uh we we
detect a difference in its role uh for
predicting the overall survival for two
treatment amps
and in summary we observe
um
that for the patient population uh we
have a number of early stage colon
cancer is expanding throughout the years
one is you know the the it's possible
that the healthcare system is expanding
their business but it's also it might be
due to like uh we have better screening
right so we have a more early detection
of the cancer and uh some of the
prevalence of the clinical conditions
are also uh evolving over time uh the
relevant one thing that's probably
relevant is like other symptoms
involving abnormal and pelvis that's so
basically what's going on in the
vicinity and it might affected you know
how difficult the procedure gonna be
right so the inflammation in the other
uh
all dancing up on me and they probably
might also create a risk and a challenge
and we also noticed that treatment
pattern is evolving like the number of
AAC is increasing over the time from 81
in the first period to 305 in the last
period and we also see an increasing
rate of our AC for a stage two and three
cancer
patients and we also see a general
improving of overall survival and the
possible explanation of this is like you
know we have a increasing confidence of
Lac over time so it's you know so it has
been used in distinguishably you know
compared to the classical OC
um and also we might have a new targeted
therapy so that the patient with
recurrence and events and a progression
they had better survival right over the
time so later patients have a better
survival
so in summary we perform a capital uh
data curation analysis to ensure the
quality of the rcd emulation with our
EHR data and uh this will um you know we
try to be automated but still I would
say a guidance from the subject matter
analogy is recommended
um and we uh we use the
phenotyping method map for the disease
cohort construction and we learned the
medical notes with the and
NLP tools we extract like a cancer stage
right from it directly and we also match
the um some implicit design of The
Guiding RC like you know the gap between
the diagnosis and the colectomy which
would not be listed as a you know a
criteria but we have to be in this uh
have this such a matter of knowledge and
we also capture uh confounding from some
other
diagnosis and symptoms
co-occurring and we just for various
temporal Trends in analysis so all these
knowledge they are very useful if later
we want to design a pre-specified
analysis plan as advocated by some of
other people in the field uh to reduce
uh objective bias right so even if like
you might have a free specific plan
would eliminated the subject device but
you know if you have a poor method then
you know some skill objective advice can
be there so this is kind of helping to
solve that issue
and some further discussion is like this
temporal Trends in real world evidence
uh have been found to uh hinders uh EHR
respiration tools as reported in a um I
think a Viewpoint paper of a union
Journal of Medicine and uh you know
basically if you use a method of the
training one year it can fail uh like
abruptly in a future year if something
has changed either administratively or
clinically right so so our study
demonstrated the various temporal
Transit may affect for real whatever the
study for treatment comparison and also
is related to a another Hot Topic like
we're gonna use external control
especially historical control uh for a
future uh clinical uh like a regulatory
purpose the clinical trial
um so a major uh however that's like a
temporal Trend might make this
inappropriate if things have changed
rapidly right so you always have a
better outcome with the newly conducted
uh like a randomized thing to try a
verse like a clinical a single arm trial
versus a historical uh arm because you
know the management in the back in those
years were poor so you have to caution
must be taken and also we also offer a
way to adjust for things using models so
I think you know even if this has been
done on display certain mathematical
adjustment is needed to First
investigate existence of trans a
dissectedness like using some analysis
to eject adjust for the the the the
effect right from those uh temporal
trends
and here is the end of my talk and in
the rest are the you know the papers
have come across uh during my talk so
you can
um
go through them if you are interested in
any aspect of the uh the study
so that's it